ils formaient leur propre chaîne humaine
pour contrôler la foule pour permettre à
justin trudeau de circuler au temple
d'or l'édifice le plus sacré des sikhs
le premier ministre était le bienvenu
c'est un art est tout désigné pour un
politicien qui veut se montrer sensible
à cette communauté et par le fait même à
la diaspora sic au canada qui compte
près d'un demi million personnes
stephen rapp elle avait d'ailleurs mis
aussi visiter mais juste un peu d'eau
était accompagnée de ses quatre ministre
sic et des députés libéraux l'ont aussi
rejoint en n beaucoup de monde beaucoup
de photos
mais il se défend d'avoir en tête la
prochaine élection ce voyage a toujours
été ancré dans le désir d'approfondir
les liens économiques interpersonnelles
politique entre le canada et l'inde et à
la mi-chemin du voyage on peut voir que
ça a déjà été un grand succès ce grand
succès c'est entre autres selon lui les
emplois et les contrats annoncés par des
compagnies canadiennes et indienne mais
l'opposition officielle n'a pas la même
définition de succès c'est un chef de
parti politique est très attaché à son
image qui fait beaucoup d'enfants sont
l'image mais qui donne strictement rien
en termes de résultats économiques ou
enfin si peu parce que il s'est trompé
de 750 millions dans sont maintenant il
reste encore trois jours à ce voyage en
aide au programme d'autres visites de
lieux de culte
d'autres discours à saveur économique et
une rencontre avec le premier ministre
indien
il reste donc trois jours à justin
trudeau pour changer les perceptions de
ceux qui doutent de la pertinence de son
voyage
et si madeleine des morins radio canada
new delhi